Speaker 1: The Twitter bombshell that really
was not.
So let me explain the back story on this Twitter
owner.
Seems weird to say that.
But yes, Twitter owner Elon Musk started teasing
and promoting a big bombshell related to censorship
and free speech.
Hunter Biden and so many other things.
And apparently the exclusive story was given
to journalist Matt Taibbi.
And so Matt Taibbi published and we're going
to put it up on the screen a tweet thread.
What better way than to break a story about
Twitter then with a tweet thread?
Matt Taibbi Tweeting thread the Twitter files.
Now one important thing to mention and you
can decide to what degree it matters to you,
is it's logical to say, why did Matt Taibbi
get this story?
And if you look at his substack, he says he
had to agree to certain conditions in order
to get this story to begin with.
So we're going to evaluate whether this is
or isn't the bombshell that it was expected
to be.
But he says he got he had to agree to certain
conditions to get some of the materials.
And rather than explaining those conditions
in the Substack post, he simply says, I take
my job and journalism really seriously and
you've got to trust me.
You've got to trust me.
Okay, so let's go to the Twitter thread.
And when you look at it, he writes the Twitter
files.
What you're about to read is the first installment
in a series based upon thousands of internal
documents obtained by sources at Twitter.
The Twitter files tell an incredible story
from inside one of the world's largest and
most influential social media platforms.
It is a frankensteinian tale of a human built
mechanism grown out.
The control of its designer.
Twitter, in its conception, was a brilliant
tool for enabling instant mass communication,
making a true, real time global conversation
possible.
For the first time in an early conception.
Twitter more than lived up to its mission
statement, giving people the power to create
and share ideas and information instantly
without barriers.
As time progressed, however, the company was
slowly forced to add those barriers.
Some of the first tools for controlling speech
were designed to combat the likes of spam
and financial fraudsters.
Slowly, over time, Twitter staff and executives
began to find more and more uses for these
tools.
Outsiders began petitioning the company to
manipulate speech as well.
First a little, then more often, then constantly.
Now, I'm not going to go through every single
one of the tweets of his thread.
We're linking to it, and I encourage you to
look at it.
But the long and short of it is that what
this bombshell exposed is that people in the
Biden campaign team, Joe Biden campaign team,
this was 2020 when Joe Biden was not president.
He was running for president and Donald Trump
was the president.
Members of Joe Biden's team.
Would ask their contacts at Twitter to remove
what is essentially revenge porn of Hunter
Biden.
We're talking about nude images of Hunter
Biden which were being shared without his
consent.
Now, is it controversial or problematic that
there was a back channel being used?
In other words, the tweets that contained
the material of these images of Hunter Biden,
which are against Twitter's terms of service
and are illegal in almost every state.
Revenge porn.
Nude images shared without the individual
in the pictures.
Consent.
Is it a problem that there was a backchannel
used rather than the public reporting system?
Maybe.
And we can certainly talk about that.
But that is not a bombshell.
That is not a bombshell.
And so this, again, collapsing into not a
non-story, but not a very big story at all.
They're talking about, oh, this violated the
Constitution, for example.
There's nothing constitutionally even involved
here.
And legal experts quickly explained that it's
not even a government suppression of free
speech because it was the Biden campaign.
It wasn't even the government saying, hey,
you've got to act and remove these images,
which, by the way, violate your own terms
of service, as well as just about every state
law.
It was a campaign rather than the government.
So that is the story.
And you can be the judge as to whether it
is a controversial story or not.
Now, I want to address one other element to
this story, which is that there are those
on the right claiming that even me personally
that that we on the left are defending Hunter
Biden or running interference for Hunter Biden.
I really couldn't care less whether Hunter
Biden goes to prison if he is found guilty
of some crime for which he is charged after
being investigated.
That's it.
The problem with these stories is that, number
one, this particular story is about revenge
porn and content that violates Twitter's own
policy.
So this is not a story that is really where
you're going to get Hunter Biden.
And then with regard to other Hunter Biden
stories or allegations, he is not involved
in the Biden administration the way that Jared
Kushner was, the way that Ivanka Trump was
and others have been.
And so if you can charge the guy with something,
if he did something illegal, by all means,
do it.
Charge him.
I don't know anyone on the left who says,
oh, no, he should be defended or whatever.
But it is becoming that which the right says
is constantly wielded against them.
It's becoming a witch hunt.
And Republicans plan to investigate Hunter
Hunter throughout their coming two years in
control of the House of Representatives.
Absolutely bonkers.
The truth doesn't matter.
They've decided this guy is their target.
And so that's what they're doing